JAMES TAMPLIN: Hi everyone,
and welcome to Developing
Extraordinary Apps
with Firebase.
I'm James.
I'm the co-founder,
and was the CEO,
of Firebase until we joined
Google about six months ago.
I want to start on a little
bit of a personal note.
Six years ago today, I
moved to the Bay Area.
And the very first thing I
did was come to I/O 2009.
A lot has changed in six
years, and it's really great
to be back here for my
second I/O, and this time,
speaking to all of you.
So we're going to have a
brief overview of Firebase
and how we think about
application development.
But before we go deep,
I want to go broad.
So 10 years ago, if you
were starting a startup,
you had to buy physical servers.
You'd call up Dell
or HP and you'd say,
hello, I'd like a box
with the Xeon processor
and a terabyte of RAM.
And they would ship
you a physical server.
You had to find a colo facility
and maybe, every now and again,
call the nice people
at the colo facility
and ask them to reset
your physical server.
And all of this seems
unimaginable today.
The cost of these made
them inaccessible to most.
And the time to set up,
operate, manage, and maintain
seemed stunning, as well.
So it begs the question,
if this looks crazy,
what are we going to look like--
today-- to software engineers
10 years from now?
If history is any guide, we're
going to look antiquated.
Even though we've made
huge strides, the tools
and the processes that we
use to build software today
are going to feel clunky.
So where is software
development going?
We think the developer's going
to have more and more leverage.
You'll be able to
do more with less.
Specifically, you'll focus
on high level concepts,
like users, data, and tasks.
So how is Google going
to help you do this?
Today, we'll be looking
at some offerings
from Google Cloud Platform.
We'll be looking at an
overview of Firebase,
going into a feature
deep dive, and then we've
got some exciting
announcements for you, as well.
So let's start with
Google Cloud Platform.
Remember all those
physical servers?
With GCP, you do not need them.
GCP provides compute
storage, data analytics,
and several other services
that help today's developers be
more productive.
I'm going to highlight
a few of them.
First, is Google
Compute Engine, or GCE.
GCE abstracts the
physical machine
and gives you a virtual one.
This is also known as
Infrastructure as a Service.
You pay nothing for the hardware
and then you pay as you go.
With GCP, this is in
one-minute increments,
which is pretty awesome.
An abstraction above
that is containers.
So with containers,
you don't have
to think about the operational
concerns of a virtual machine.
Can we go forward in the notes?
Containers, basically,
mean that you
can run software
without thinking
about underlying hardware.
And with Google
Container Engine,
you can run your code on
a cluster of machines.
And that's done with the open
source project, Kubernetes,
which Google released last June.
One level of abstraction above
that, is Platform as a Service,
with App Engine.
With App Engine,
you further don't
need to think about memory
or CPU, OS upgrades.
You just give it
your back end code,
and App Engine takes it, deploys
it, runs it, and scales it.
And this makes developers
significantly more productive.
And so GCP has some awesome
offerings for service side back
end developers.
But what if you're a
mobile developer or a web
developer working on the client
side of your application?
Well, it turns out that
Google has a service for you.
And that brings us to Firebase.
For those of you
who aren't aware,
let's do a quick overview.
Firebase is a platform
to help you rapidly
build really great mobile
and web applications.
One of the first things you
do when building an app is you
choose how to
build its back end.
Firebase has three services--
user authentication,
a real time database,
and static hosting--
to help you build your
application without needing
to spin up servers and
without needing to manage
complex infrastructure.
This saves you an
immense amount of time.
But more importantly,
it lets you
focus on creating a
great user experience.
Your users do not care if the
code to shard your database
is elegant.
They care if you're elegantly
solving their problem.
Firebase has SDKs for
iOS, Android, and the web.
This allows you to
access Firebase directly
from your client.
With client side code,
though, you often
need to structure
and maintain it.
And this is why we've
built deep integrations
with these great front
end web frameworks.
If you want to access
Firebase from a server,
you can use our server
site libraries or wrappers
around our REST API
in these languages.
And with our REST API, you can
access Firebase from anywhere
you can do HTTP.
So how did Firebase start?
Well, 3 and 1/2 years ago,
we saw some game developers
having some trouble setting up
their back end infrastructure.
All they wanted to do was
build a really cool game.
They wanted to make
awesome artwork.
They wanted to grow their MAUs.
And they didn't want to
think about the intricacies
of a distributed
real time system.
So we started Firebase.
And today, this is one of our
customers-- Roll20-- who's
built their entire game on us.
They are just one of 190,000
developers who are building
their applications on Firebase.
And Firebase has 1 and 1/2
million end user devices
sending data through
us at any given time.
These are some of the
customers that use us.
They range from
ambitious startups
all the way up to
large enterprises.
So that's a quick
overview of Firebase.
Now let's look at our features--
authentication, database,
and hosting.
Data is the lifeblood
of any application.
So we'll start off with
the real time database.
Firebase has a
NoSQL JSON database.
One of the most exciting
features about this
is it does data synchronization.
Whenever the client
device writes to Firebase,
we synchronize that data
with the Firebase servers,
and then push it down to
every other device who cares.
This is fantastic for
this multi-device world
that we live in, where you
pick up your smartphone
and put down your
tablet and expect
to pick up where you left off.
It's also fantastic for this
world of intermittent internet
connectivity.
When you go into an elevator
or go through a tunnel,
you expect your
application to still work.
And since, with
Firebase, your SDKs
have a local view of the data--
a local copy of the data--
in memory on the device,
it means your application
does exactly this.
But it's not just
synchronization.
It's real time synchronization.
We push those updates to
other devices in milliseconds.
And this allows you to build
great, real time, collaborative
applications with Firebase.
Google Docs has set the
standard for what you can do
with real time collaboration.
And now, with Firebase, you can
build these great experiences
without needing a
huge engineering team.
But instead of telling
you, why don't I show you?
So we'll switch
over to the camera.
And we're going to show an
application called Talkboard.
Talkboard is built
by Citrix, and it's
used in schools and companies
with over hundreds of thousands
of users around the world.
So here I can select
multiple boards,
and I'm going to jump
into this one called
I/O. Now, with Firebase,
these two devices
are connected over Wi-Fi.
When I write on one, it'll
sync the data up to Firebase
and push it down to the
other device in milliseconds.
So I can say, hi I/O. And
I'll flip that around,
so we're all looking
at the same thing.
I'll find the appropriate
shade of blue.
Let's get a bit of
a fatter stencil
there, go hi, I/O. I'll
find a nice yellow,
draw a little sun up here.
So you can-- this
is all vector data,
and it's all stored as
JSON inside Firebase.
And you can see just how
quickly those updates propagate.
And just how easy it is to build
those collaborative features.
So go back to the slides.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
There are a couple
of great things
we should note about
Firebase database.
The first is that it's
accessible directly
from the client.
So you don't need
to talk to a server.
The client can just go
directly to the database.
Second-- and this is
how easy it is to do so.
So this is actually
some Android code.
First of all, we
create a reference
to a location inside Firebase.
I'm doing that up top.
And then I can just
call ref.setValue.
And I'm passing
in a string there
that says, hi, I/O.
This is all the code you
need to write to Firebase.
The Firebase database
is just one JSON object.
So it's in a format that
you're familiar with.
And it's in a format that all
of the client side devices
that you work with already use.
It's schemaless.
And so it's super flexible,
so you can structure data
how you like.
If you've already used Mongo, if
you've already used Couchbase,
Firebase's database is going
to feel really familiar to you.
And finally, every piece
of data has its own URL.
JSON is a tree structure.
URLs are a tree structure.
So we've mapped
every piece of data.
Every number, every Boolean,
every string, to its own URL.
This gives you several
great benefits.
First of all, it's intuitive.
So you can reference data
with an absolute path
or with a relative path.
And it's all in a format
that you know and understand.
Second of all, you can use
those URLs as REST endpoints,
so you can manage and manipulate
from REST, in addition
to the client libraries.
And finally, it's
browser compatible.
So you can actually punch
those URLs into a web browser
and you see a graphical
view of your data.
And this is fantastic
if you're debugging.
I want to talk a little bit
about accessing Firebase
from the client.
Typically, when you
build applications,
you're building them in a
three-tier architecture.
So your device talks to
an application server,
and that, in turn, then
talks to a database.
As I mentioned, this isn't
the case with Firebase.
We view application
development as moving
to a two-tier model, where
the device speaks directly
to the Firebase database.
And this gives you a
couple of benefits.
First, it allows you to do the
real time in the offline mode
that I mentioned.
But it also speeds
up development.
There's no server
boilerplate code
that's shuffling data
between your database
and your application server.
When you add a
feature, you don't
need to go and add
new server code,
or add new tests to that code.
So it really does
speed up development.
And then you're also
offloading scaling to Firebase.
So you don't need to
re-architect your server
code to scale.
Firebase already guides
you into a pattern
where your operations on
your data scale linearly
with the size of your data set.
This is how most
high scale production
apps are written, anyway.
And you're doing it
from the very beginning.
With a two-tier
architecture, you
may be asking, how
do I run server code,
if I want to run
some trusted code?
Or if I want to do some
heavy lifting that I don't
want the edge phone to do?
Well, you can just hook a
server up the Firebase database
directly.
And you can also connected
with third party APIs.
And you may be thinking
to yourself out
in the audience,
OK, that's great.
But if my device is talking
directly to my Firebase
database, how do I secure it?
And the answer is with our
flexible rules language.
So this language lets you define
how your data can be structured
and who can access it.
These live on our server, and
here's an example of them.
So here are my rules language.
I'm saying the foo node
can be read by anyone,
it can be written by anyone.
And then I have a validate
rule that enforces the schema.
So it's got to be
a string and it's
got to be less than
100 characters.
These are all in one place.
They're stored in the Firebase
servers, and they're all JSON.
Again, you can upload
them with our CLI
or edit them directly
at Firebase.com.
So we've taken a look at
the Firebase database.
Now let's move to
Firebase authentication.
Most every app has
the concept of a user.
Unfortunately, the
first thing you
do when you set up
set up an app is
have to write a user
authenication system
or fight with OAuth.
With Firebase, we enable
you to easily implement
email and password and then
connect with third party
providers, like Google,
Facebook, Twitter, and GitHub.
And you can do
this really easily.
This is the code in JavaScript
implement Facebook login
with Firebase authentication.
I create a reference,
as we saw earlier,
and I call
ref.authWithOAuthPopup
and I pass it to string
Facebook, give it a callback.
That's it.
I can change that to Twitter.
I can change that to Google.
And that's all I need
to do to implement log
in with a third party provider.
Really is that simple.
So what if you're asking, how
do I actually integrate it
with my existing user system?
I already built one.
And the answer
is, you can easily
use one of our eight server
side libraries to integrate.
You just generate a JSON web
token, another open standard,
and that'll tell Firebase
who your user is.
But our Firebase
authentication also
works with our security
rules that I just mentioned.
This enables you to build
secure applications with a user
authentication system.
So let's say we
have a users node.
$uid basically specifies that
we can interact with any user
entry in the user's node.
It's saying that anyone
can read a user's profile,
but only the person logged in
can modify their own profile.
It's that easy with just
a few lines of code.
Finally, let's look
at Firebase hosting.
It's production-grade
hosting for developers.
So Firebase hosting was designed
for mission-critical sites
and apps, and we built it
for reliability and scale.
It runs some great sites,
like Firebase.com, Angular,
and the Polymer
team user, as well.
It's backed by global CDN, so
you get pops around the world.
It's SSL by default. We even
provision SSL cert for you.
So you don't have to go
off and buy the $150 cert.
And it has custom domain
support so you can hook it up
to your own custom domain.
You just go into your terminal,
go to the directory you want,
call firebase imit.
And then you can
call firebase deploy
and it'll push that content
up to your own Firebaseapp.com
URL or your own custom URL.
So we've seen Firebase
authentication real time
database and Firebase hosting.
Now let's take a look at some of
the customers who use Firebase.
Instacart is one of the rising
stars in Silicon Valley.
They let you do grocery
delivery from your mobile app
to your door in hours.
And they've been using
Firebase since the beginning.
They've raised over $300
million from top-tier VCs
and they use Firebase
for a number of things.
You can collaboratively
edit your shopping cart
with your roommate or spouse.
You can talk to your shopper
while they're in the store.
And you can also see where your
order is with their live order
location tracking.
The next customer's a little
bit of a different profile.
So Sky News was the UK'S
first 24-hour news network.
They're based in London.
They have new bureaus
around the globe.
And on May the seventh, the
UK held general election.
For those of you unfamiliar
with British parliamentary
procedure, until this
year, an election
would be called within
a five-year window.
And as soon as it was
called, then six weeks later,
the election happened.
So this six-weeks election
cycle makes some democracies,
I know, feel like
a walk in the park.
Sky News used Firebase to
synchronize election data
from their iOS app, their
Android app, and their web app.
So that on the night
of May the seventh,
and the morning
of May the eighth,
the millions of people from
around the world who tuned in
to watch the most-watched
election in UK history
got the updates with Firebase.
We're really excited
that this software was
built in a matter of
weeks by their team
and achieved this scale.
Next up, we have Citrix.
So Citrix uses us in some of
their flagship applications
like GoToMeeting and GoToAssist.
Well one of their newest
applications uses us, too.
Today, I'm excited to
welcome onto the stage
Gus Pinto, senior
director at Citrix,
who's going to tell us a
little bit about how Citrix
is using us in Concierge.
So we'll switch over to the--
GUS PINTO: Good
morning, everyone.
I'm really jazzed to be joining
the Firebase team and James
here.
We built a wonderful
relationship
that expands on the
original relationship we'd
had with Google.
You see, Citrix-- we have a
pretty mission-critical task
at hand.
OK?
We power over 400
million workspace users
every single day.
And one thing that
we did notice is
that the vast majority of our
mobile users are going mobile--
are getting the work done
on a mobile workspace.
And it really dawned upon us
that the vehicles in which we
support customers today on
mobile devices is antiquated
and it's really, really bad.
I mean, to the point of being
frustrating to the most part.
Things like-- the best
things that we can come up
with sometimes was just
putting a button in our apps
that sends an email
form to somebody,
when the problems that we
have are happening right now.
That's why we've
created Concierge.
We really just re-imagined the
communication flow and the way
companies connect with their
customers and employees.
And we launched
it two weeks ago.
And beyond our
wildest expectations,
we sold out our tech preview
in the very first day.
And quite honestly, we couldn't
have done that without Google.
Now we do leverage a lot
of components of Google
across our technologies.
In the case of Concierge,
we use WebRTC and Chrome.
We have an SDK for
Android, we leverage Cast.
But at the very
heart of Concierge--
and really what enabled us
to get here-- was Firebase.
I say it's in the
heart of our product
because it's the ticking
component that makes everything
flow within our product.
From user
authentication, as James
alluded, to the real time
data from end to end.
We had to reinvent the
inbox for agents-- our chat
communication-- and so many
other components all the way
to signaling for WebRTC.
We really rely
heavily on Firebase.
And I could just spend the time
here telling you about this.
I'd rather show you
what this looks like
and what we've
managed to accomplish
with our partnership.
So I think there's nothing
better than to truly show
a live product.
Nothing more
dangerous and better
than to show a live product.
So we brought a customer
product to show you guys.
And it's from a company
called Modernizing Medicine.
And what those guys are doing
in their own environment,
in the medical space, is
reinventing and reimagining
how physicians
interact with patients.
And they're doing
it from anywhere
and bringing the power of
electronic medical record
systems to mobile.
Now what I want to do
is fire it up here.
And hopefully, you
guys can see it good.
I'll log in.
Now with Concierge,
what we've done
was-- as part of reimagining
how we would support customers
on the go-- was,
first, something
that actually Google's very
keen on, which is contacts.
Trying to get support
in today's apps--
whether it's the email form,
or going out of your app,
scrambling, finding
a 1-800 number,
calling somebody, and
eventually being frustrated,
giving up, and going and
bashing them on Twitter--
it's rather frustrating.
So we figured that the
place to start-- it's
what makes our product really
smart, which are the apps.
In the case of Modernizing
Medicine, what they've done
is they've integrated
Concierge, which
is a simple SDK you
plug into your app.
And with one line of
code, just fire up
an entire suite of technologies
that allows you to communicate
real time with your customers.
And in the case of real time, we
mean with the push of a button,
you can get audio-- like
a normal internet call
right within your
app-- a video--
so you can see the
representative that's
helping you in real time,
or just a simple chat,
if you're not fond of having
a conversation through audio
and video.
So what I'm going to do here is
go ahead and start a new visit.
And simple things-- like,
say, I'm a physician,
the application
has been updated,
something moved and changed,
and I don't know what it is.
And I'm a doctor and
I'm kind of lost.
And I don't want to go to a
consultation with my patient
and be like, I don't
know what's going on.
JAMES TAMPLIN: I didn't
know you were a doctor, Gus.
GUS PINTO: I am a
doctor to make believe.
JAMES TAMPLIN: OK.
You're like Doogie Howser.
GUS PINTO: So what
I'm going to do here
is I started a
new constultation,
but I forgot, with this new
UI, how to properly document
this visit.
So what the guys
from ModMed have done
is they embedded our
SDK into their product.
It took them less
than 20 minutes.
Trust me, the developer of the
product is here in the audience
and he can hold me up to it.
And with the push
of a button, it
comes up on their own UI that
confirms that you actually
want to get support.
And what that does--
when I press this button,
it goes out there and
establishes a connection
on Concierge.
And as you can see-- can we
switch back to the Notebook?
Thank you.
That puts, instantly,
a new session
within our inbox, where the
ticketing system happens.
And James will be
my support agent.
JAMES TAMPLIN: I'd be happy to.
So I'll go ahead and
answer the call here.
And I've got an incoming call.
So I'll accept.
GUS PINTO: So voila.
So right within our app, we
have a live support agent.
Now can we switch back, real
quick, to the [? Wolf ?].
Now you see that we can-- let
me hit OK here to confirm.
Now we're sharing my screen.
So you can see that
James-- I can just
move him around the screen,
and it's really swift.
And he can hear me
and I can hear him.
But one thing that
happened here was just
getting the communication
flow between the customer
and the company was not enough.
Tools to get proper support
for mobile customers
really didn't exist.
So we had to create
something new.
And we call that Copilot,
which is the ability for you
to share everything that's in
the screen of the customer's
computer in real
time, whether it's
an iOS device or an Android
device or a web app.
As well as the camera,
because most of these devices
have a camera.
And sometimes the problem's not
necessarily in the app itself,
but in the real
world and something
you want to interact with.
As well as information, like
what the device version is
and what the battery level,
what the Wi-Fi, and things
of such nature.
JAMES TAMPLIN: So how
can I help you today?
What seems to be the problem?
GUS PINTO: So I
forgot how to document
a session with this patient.
And since the UI changed, I
really don't know how it is.
JAMES TAMPLIN: You're
a terrible doctor.
GUS PINTO: I'm a
horrible doctor.
JAMES TAMPLIN: So if you
want to start an exam,
what you're going to want to do
is click this exam button here
in the upper left.
And I'll just
highlight that for you.
GUS PINTO: Cool.
So you see that right on
the iPad, whatever he did,
he could draw on my screen
and guide me to completion.
And we call that
feature Touch Assist.
He can actually see where I
tap on the screen in real time.
So if we switch
back to Notebook,
he can see the drawing.
You can see he can
simply clear the drawing.
JAMES TAMPLIN: Cool.
So I'll clear that
with the eraser.
GUS PINTO: Once I touch where
I need to touch-- and all
the touches that I do--
I perform-- they show up
in real time.
Including any updates I
make to the application.
JAMES TAMPLIN: Just going
to give her a little hair.
I could totally
be a doctor, too.
GUS PINTO: And
then from here, we
expect to be able to drive
problem solutions much faster
than ever before.
You know?
So this is Concierge.
It's in the market today.
You can go to
concierge.call.com.
It's available for
both Android and iOS.
And we believe that
it's really going
to transform the way companies
connect with their customers
and employees.
And we really couldn't
have built this
without the help of
Firebase because we really
had a hard set of
problems to tackle.
And instead of trying
to reinvent the wheel,
we made a commitment to build
this on a solid platform that
would scale for us at the
enterprise-grade levels
that we really needed to.
So that's Concierge.
JAMES TAMPLIN: Awesome.
GUS PINTO: And take
Firebase for a spin.
You will absolutely love it.
Thank you, James.
JAMES TAMPLIN: Thanks
for your time, Gus.
Really appreciate it.
GUS PINTO: Absolutely.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMES TAMPLIN: Cool.
So we've seen how Instacart,
Sky News, and Citrix
use Firebase to power some
of their applications.
Now let's get to some of
the really exciting bits.
We've got a couple of
great announcements today.
And the first is a new feature
for our real time database.
Typically, when you're
building a mobile application,
it's just consuming a
REST API from a server.
And in this
architecture, when you
lose your internet connection,
the app just stops working.
And this is a terrible
user experience.
We learned earlier that
the Firebase client
SDKs keep a local copy of your
data in memory on your phone.
And so this allows your
app to stay responsive
when you lose your
connection temporarily.
But today, we're
improving on that.
And we're improving on that by
announcing full mobile offline
support.
[APPLAUSE]
This comes in two flavors.
The first is disk persistence.
So when you go
offline, your SDKs now
not only store into memory,
but they also persist to disk.
This means you can completely
quit your application
and when you restart it,
your data is still available.
When you come back
online, it resyncs
and the entire application
brings you back up
to speed and back up to the
current state of the world.
Let's hop over to the
[? Wolf ?] and let's
show you this in action.
So this has actually already
been implemented on Talkboard.
So this time, let's play a
little game of tic-tac-toe.
But all of a sudden, I lose
my internet connection.
So I'm going to come in
here and turn off the Wi-Fi.
And I'm going to
go to the Wi-Fi.
And I'll go back to Talkboard.
So now we've lost the
internet connection.
So the first thing I'll do
is I'll start playing again.
And I realize the other
player's isn't connected,
so I'm just going to go
ahead and win the game
because they're not there.
And then I'll go ahead and quit
my application entirely and say
I'm off climbing a mountain.
Meanwhile, the other player is
like, what actually happened?
Where did you go?
And draws a question mark.
A while later, I spin the
application back up, I go out.
Fire it up again.
Go into Talkboard.
Here's my game of tic-tac-toe.
And then I turn
the Wi-Fi back on.
First of all, you've seen
that I quit the application,
the data was persisted to disk,
I restarted the application,
everything is still there.
Then, when I reconnect to
Wi-Fi, turn it back on.
This, by the way, is the
only demo of my career
that if the Wi-Fi actually drops
out, it would be a good thing.
And as we regain Wi-Fi,
everything syncs back
and we're up to the
current state of the world.
[APPLAUSE]
We really need to focus
on mobile as developers,
and features like this
let you do exactly that.
We'll go back to the slides.
Another great thing
is that this feature
is available with
just one line of code.
This is the Android, the
Objective-C, and the Swift code
that you need to enable
this persistence.
Because Firebase database is
built on a synchronization
approach, we've really built
it-- from the beginning--
to be able to do this.
And we're excited
that there's GA today.
The next peeks of full mobile
offline support is Keep Synced.
Keep Synced is the
ability for you
to specify data that
should be prefetched
and kept up to date in
case you go offline.
So a good example
of this is if you're
building a social
network and you
want to keep the profiles of
your closest friends up to date
so that you can get at
them if you're offline.
Keep Synced is the
feature that would
allow you to do this
and see their wall
posts from the last time you
had an internet connection.
This is, again, just one
line of code to implement.
Here's the Android, the
Objective-C, and the Swift code
to do it again.
With both disk persistence
and with Keep Synced,
if your users go through
tunnels, climb a mountain,
or get on a plane,
your applications
continue to work seamlessly.
And since this is
just one line of code,
this continues to be a hallmark
of Firebase-- our simplicity
and our ease of use.
And you can now
deliver these features
that your users are
coming to expect.
The second announcement
we have today
is around making
Firebase compatible with
an exciting new technology.
Firebase is just one piece
of a complete application.
As I mentioned earlier,
client side code
often needs to be
structured and managed.
And that's why we've
built integrations
with Angular, Ember, React.
But an exciting new technology,
called React Native,
was announced a
couple of months ago.
And today, we're excited
to announce that Firebase
works with React
Native and can be
the back end for your
React Native-powered app.
React Native is an open
source library from Facebook.
There's a huge community
going around it.
It already has 14,000
stars on GitHub
and it's used by Facebook
in their Groups product.
Firebase and React work
really well with each other.
React updates your
UI when there's
a change in your data model.
Firebase delivers real time
updates to your data model.
The pairing is quite elegant.
You can get started by
npm installing Firebase,
and then, inside your
React Native code,
just require Firebase and
you're off to the races.
We really can't wait
to see what you build.
So you've seen our
mobile offline support
and our React announcements.
We've seen what Google
Cloud Platform can
do to help you be more
productive, an overview
of Firebase and a feature
deep dive, heard from Citrix,
and seen some announcements.
Really focusing on user
experience, not infrastructure,
is going to be the way
developers build apps
in the future.
Focusing on tasks,
users, and data.
Firebase is enabling developers
to deliver extraordinary apps,
with features that end users
expect right out of the box.
With Firebase, what used to
take months now takes hours.
We live in pretty
exciting times.
And we're excited that
individual developers
and small teams can make
a massive difference.
If you build something
with Firebase,
please do tell us about it.
We'd love to hear
what you build.
We'll be around all day.
We have office hours at 4:00 PM.
There's some schwag
over on these tables.
We're here in the yellow shirts.
Please come and find
us and say hello.
And enjoy the rest of
your I/O. Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]